hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute geht es etwas leckeres
zu ostern aber auch passend zum frühling
und er sich auch ein klassiker denn
heute gibt einen kuchen mit vanille
frosting frosting deutsche sprache na ja
ich mache jetzt zuerst den teig das ist
ein ganz normaler rührteig auf butter
basis ihr könntet auch einen auf ölbasis
machen aber ich find bei dem karotten
kuchen schmeckt einfach mit butter
bisschen besser sie eigentlich hier die
zutaten
ich habe hier 250 gramm partie ist schon
zimmer waren
ich brauche eine prise salz und ein
bisschen vanille extrakt hier habe ich
220 gramm zucker drei eier die sind auch
zimmer waren dann brauche ich 350 gramm
karotten die sind bereits geschält und
das geschickte gewicht sind 350 gramm
500 gramm mehl
ich habe mich noch 100 gramm nüsse wobei
ich jetzt mandeln genommen habe und habe
einfach gehackte und gemahlene mandeln
gemischt zwei teelöffel zimt
hier habe ich zwei teelöffel backpulver
und einen teelöffel natron ihr könnt
aber auch einfach ein päckchen
backpulver benutzen falls jetzt kann
natron habt und ich brauche noch ein
bisschen milch das sind ungefähr so 200
milliliter die ich auch zu erkennen und
das erste was jetzt macht ist dass sich
die karotten jetzt rastner ich mach das
jetzt einfach kurz mit der
küchenmaschine und nehmen da jetzt ein
aufsatz wo die karotte einfach schön
klein gebastelt wird
jetzt nehme ich einfach die karotte und
raspelt sie einmal kurz durch
ja
jetzt gebe ich zuerst die butter in die
rührschüssel und da ist eben wichtig
dass ihr zimmer war mich ansonsten
verbindet sie sich nicht so gut mit dem
zucker und mit den eiern und man kann
sie halt dann auch nicht so schön
geschmeidig rühren und ich gebe jetzt
gleich noch die prise salz dazu und
etwas vanille extrakt falls ihr das
atmen da einfach vanillezucker wobei da
hallt es auch über jedem intensiver ist
jetzt genau der richtige zug an auch mit
dazu entschlossen besitzer etwa vier bis
zu drei bis vier minuten verrühren
dieses eben schon weiß cremig wird erst
auf niedriger stufe und dann schalte ich
gleich bisschen höher und sammelt hier
noch den zugang
jetzt gebe ich hier noch nacheinander
die eier dazu und lasst sie auch noch
kurz verrühren
also bis es schön homogen ist
das reicht schon
und jetzt kann ich hier in einer
schüssel mehl mit backpulver und natron
vermische jetzt gut so dann gibt es
nämlich keine klümpchen und jetzt gebe
ich einfach die restlichen zutaten noch
mit rein dass auch die kapuze dann das
mit dem backpulver und dem natron
ziemlich viel teig aber ich mag das auch
gleich in dem blech die nüsse bzw die
mandeln zimt und jetzt gebe ich auch ein
bisschen milch statt so noch nicht
komplett alles so ein bisschen lasse ich
mir übrig es kann auch sein dass nämlich
weniger braucht kommt einfach darauf an
wie groß die eier sind jetzt ganz
langsam rühren wobei ich wohl ihrem
schwarzbuch spritzschutz
so werde ich habe jetzt die komplette
mensch dazu gegeben ich hatte auch eier
in größe m
falls sie zum beispiel größere hat
brauchte die wahrscheinlich nicht
komplett und jetzt gebe ich das ganze
immer ein vorbereitetes backblech ich
habe jetzt hier mein backblech mit
backpapier armen und backt es darin ihr
könnt aber auch ein ganz normales
backblech benutzen also das gilt auch
wenn diese datei geschätzt nicht flüssig
also dass ich ein ziemlich fester teil
und das muss jetzt darin schön glatt
gestrichen
und jetzt gebe ich den teig bei 175 grad
ober und unterhitze in den vorgeheizten
backofen
da muss er jetzt ungefähr 30 bis 35
minuten backen
ich mache auf jeden fall auch die
stäbchen probe und dann lasse ich ihn ab
ein kuchen ist es bereits abgekühlt und
tabak folie und back rahmen entfernt und
stellt das kurz zur seite
denn ich möchte jetzt noch im wandel
frosting drauf machen und braucht dafür
nur wenige zutaten und zwar habe ich
hier 100 gramm frischkäse das ist so ein
also mit doppelnamen stufe 100 gramm
puderzucker
hier habe ich noch ein bisschen vanille
als von dem wandel extrakt ein teelöffel
milch und ein telefon apfelsaft da kann
man auch zitronensaft oder orangensaft
nehmen braucht nur ein bisschen säure
und für die deko nämlich so ein paar
mini märchen die habe ich jetzt diesmal
fertig gekauft gibt es normalerweise in
grösseren supermärkten
ich habs jetzt beim globus gekauft und
jetzt geht es ganz einfach und zwar gebe
ich einfach den frischkäse da rein
man könnte auch bisserl mehr frosting
machen aber ich mag es nicht wenn du so
dick da drauf dann liegt sondern macht
es eher so ein bisschen als gus und gibt
in puderzucker mit ryan und auch die
anderen so taten die flüssigkeiten und
natürlich ganz wichtig die vanille und
da wünscht ihr euch empfehlen entweder
dieses vanille extrakt zu nehmen oder
ein vanillemark us von einer
vanilleschote und das frühere ich jetzt
hier kommt nun schneebesen auf niedriger
stufe
und jetzt auch das ist jetzt ziemlich
flüssig ich möchte es aber so wenn ihr
sehr feste haben wollte lass dir einfach
die milch und den apfelsaft einfach weg
jetzt verteidigt das hier drüber und
muss ich dann nur noch verstreichen
und jetzt schneidet den kuchen in kleine
würfel
ich mache jetzt schön klein denn ich
will sie gleich einen muffin förmchen
reinsetzen praktisch zum anrichten
hmm
jetzt könnt ihr hier einfach auf ein
paar noch diese märchen drauf setzen so
ein bisschen als deko was aber auch gut
passen würde wären zum beispiel einfach
ein paar schokoraspeln oder so ein paar
testen von der orange und stand damals
gleich reagieren
so sehen jetzt die fed dekorierten
möhren kuchen aus und am besten
schmecken sie frisch aus dem kühlschrank
denn dann wird auch das frosting diese
klausur noch ein bisschen fest
und das ist so ein tag der ist ziemlich
feucht deswegen muss man aufpassen wenn
man den vom backpapier unterzieht das
ist nicht so klebt und ich probierte
sitzt auch gar nicht weil es so hübsch
aussieht und ich mach gleich noch ein
foto für instagram da könnt ihr nämlich
auch vorbeischauen da gibt es nicht auch
intercell ist orten welt und ich freue
mich wenn ich da auch ein paar bilder
hinschickt bzw wenn ihr da mich immer
markiert mit dem hashtag stylist orten
welt und wir lassen uns die jetzt gleich
mit einem kaffee schmecken und das
rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auf salehs
- blog.de bis bald